now to a health warning affecting the
entire country medical experts are
sounding the alarm about a possible
triple democ that could unfold this
winter yep a triple demick that means
cases of covet flew an RSV a virus
that's been impacting children are all
expected to rise we spoke earlier with
White House coveted response coordinator
that's Dr Ashish Jah
this phrase triple demick please explain
good morning Gail thanks for having me
back
um yeah it's you know always concerning
when you have three respiratory viruses
RSV influenza and covid rising at the
same time obviously that's something
we're going to monitor very closely but
the good news here Gail is that we're
not powerless against this right we have
flu shots that keep people out of the
hospital we have covet shots we have a
brand new Cova chat that is formulated
against the virus that's out there right
now that will keep people out of the
hospital prevent people from getting
seriously ill so if people went out and
got their vaccines we could really get
through this without getting into a lot
of trouble I hope so I just went and got
my brand new covet shot I feel really
good about this but what are you most
concerned about right now you've got
you're dealing with three things three
issues what are you most concerned about
right now well obviously the thing that
we always are paying attention to is
making sure there's plenty of Hospital
capacity and that Healthcare capacity
doesn't start getting stretched and uh
with all three of them if all three of
them rise at the same time again if
people are not vaccinated uh then we can
start seeing a lot more hospitalizations
hospitals are Hospital capacity is very
important we need hospitals for all
sorts of things not just those viruses
so right now our focus is get people
vaccinated get people treated and keep
people out of the hospital
I have a lot of friends very educated
smart people who say look I've got
vaccine fatigue I'm not getting another
shot what do you say to those people
you're worried about vaccine fatigue
yeah yeah what I say is look you know
for every year for the last 20 years
I've got gone out and gotten a flu shot
every fall uh you know it's like it's
just part of being healthy in the fall
and winter that's where we are with
covet as well so for most Americans it's
now a once a year shot go out and get
your fall covet shot it's updated it's
targeting the virus that's out there it
really will make an enormous difference
and then you're good to go for most
people you're good to go for a year and
don't have to think about vaccines again
for a while
there's no vaccine for the RSV for
little children what should parents do
what what should they do what should
they know about this yeah not yet I know
there are a couple of companies working
on it and my hope is within a year we
will have it again for most people who
get RSV it's pretty mild young kids as
you said can get into trouble with
breathing issues what I you know what
I'd say is there are lots of standard
ways of avoiding it right like avoid
sick contacts if you have a sick kid
keep them at home wash your hands those
are things that really make a difference
in keeping RSV levels low I mean
obviously if you have a child who gets
sick and if they start having any kind
of difficulties with with breathing then
obviously you got to go get them seen by
a pediatrician got to get them seen by a
doctor
right now the government for the most
part pays for the coveted vaccine when
do you expect that to stop you know
Pfizer just announced they're going to
start charging 130 dollars per shot
after the contract runs out when do you
think the government is going to stop
paying for the covet shots yeah it's a
great question I mean right now we have
plenty of vaccines that we have bought
for Americans and so this fall winter
into early part of 23 I think people
should know that covered vaccines will
remain free for all Americans at some
point in 2023 especially given that
Congress has stopped funding this
altogether sometime in 2023 I do expect
that transition to happen but we just
don't have a date right now when exactly
that'll happen
all right but we'll count on you to keep
us updated Dr Ashish jaw always good to
see you thanks for your time thank you